do you have a favorite the quieter one
with the sugar daddy the sugar daddy got
them do with me
$800 seems way off for radio but I know
how about we give a four really what you
was the clock
oh I dude I got the info right here all
right let's see here we'll see this
first if it's your pleasure
what's the info right here wait what are
we looking for
I'm gonna need some more of that
thinking so with a thinking powder but
there you go it's just a stock radio is
it an aftermarket wear-and-tear bad
music you know for 400 case closed
if not they're gonna argue out there for
two hours we don't have the time to it
your honor we got a full docket get them
saying hey I like static spread up a big
old jar I'm here so we are cold dark in
a big jar reefer it's 60 miles to
Chicago stark and we're wearing
sunglasses it was more than 60 miles and
blues brothers wasn't it I don't
remember yeah a lot more miles I think
[Music]